[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon and welcome I'm Kim van
Devere the chairman of the MIT faculty
we gather here today to honor two people
James R Killian jr. and professor Noam
Chomsky the Killian award is the highest
award that the MIT faculty bestows upon
one of its own it's named after the late
Jim Killian tenth president of MIT he
came to MIT as a student in the mid
1920s he joined the staff of Technology
Review 1926 and he retired as chairman
of the MIT corporation 45 years later in
1971 he brought great honor and
distinction to MIT through his many
years of national service I'll mention
two examples which are just the tip of
the iceberg in the late 1950s he was the
first full-time science advisor to a
President of the United States and
provided important leadership in the
period that set the nation's course to
putting a man on the moon he also served
as chairman of the Carnegie Commission
on educational television which
recommended the formation of the
Corporation for Public Broadcasting he
was also a very genuine and likable
person as I discovered quite by accident
one day about 20 years ago when I was a
new graduate student at MIT I sat down
at a table in the lobby L dining-room
with an elderly gentleman that I didn't
know and we struck up a conversation one
that was to begin
a long series of enlightening
conversations I had with him till the
time of his death in 1988 because the
easy way with students and with other
members of the MIT community or one of
the things that define Jim Killian to us
this award is named in his honor we
bestow it upon a faculty member each
year who is also brought honor and
distinction to MIT professor Chomsky has
been doing so for 37 years as a member
of our faculty professor Chomsky would
you come to the stage please in
preparing for today I did one small
piece of research on professor Chomsky
which I'd like to share with you with
the help of the MIT library staff I was
able to determine how often he is cited
in the arts and humanities Citation
Index as of the last time the statistics
were compiled we discovered that he is
in the top 10 it happens
that none of the others are still living
hee hee is the most cited living author
I thought you might like to know the
names of the company he keeps
they are in order Marx Lenin
Shakespeare Aristotle the Bible Plato
Freud Chomsky followed by Hegel and
Cicero
I would like to read from the award
it says the president and faculty of the
Massachusetts Institute of Technology
have the honor to present the James our
Killian junior faculty achievement award
to Noam Chomsky and to announce his
appointment as Killian Award lecturer
for the academic year 91-92 in
recognition of his extraordinary
contributions to linguistics philosophy
and cognitive psychology one of the
foremost thinkers of this century he
revolutionized the study of language and
of the human mind his books monographs
and articles constitute major milestones
in the history of linguistics an
inspiring teacher he has trained
scholars who are among the most
important contributors to the discipline
his presence here has greatly enriched
mit president Chomsky the microphone is
here
he's lucky he didn't read what the
citations say the the title of this talk
announced title has three parts refers
to language the cognitive revolutions
and then there's the quotes around
cognitive revolutions the the relation
between language and cognitive science
is natural that's a reasonable
combination modern linguistics developed
as part of what's sometimes called the
cognitive revolution of the 1950s
actually to a large extent here in
building 20 thanks initially to Jerry
Wiesner
initiatives it was also a major factor
in the development of the cognitive
sciences ever since their modern origins
so those two words are sort of obvious
the quotes are intended to express a
lingering skepticism and when I say
cognitive revolution from here on in
you're supposed to hear so-called
cognitive revolution I'll explain why as
I proceeded the skepticism that I feel
does not have anything to do with the
actual work that's done in the various
areas of cognitive science so vision
language cognitive development a few
others in these areas there have been
quite significant advances over the past
40 years the questions in my mind arise
at a second-order level that is thinking
about the nature of the disciplines that
are concerned with what we're
traditionally called mental acts or
mental faculties and I want to come back
to a few of those questions some of them
are substantive some of them are
historical first a few words about the
contemporary cognitive sciences and the
cognitive revolution as they look to me
and let me stress that others don't see
it this way at all this is not intended
to be a survey but rather a rather
personal point of view George Miller who
was one of the leading figures and
founders of the modern field in a recent
article he he traced the modern
cognitive sciences back to a meeting in
1956 held in Cambridge I can't remember
whether it was here at Harvard but one
or the other it was a meeting which of
the Institute of radio engineers which
had a series of papers on experimental
human psychology which made use of
information theory and signal detection
and other then pretty new ideas I'd had
a paper of mine on language which
outlined some of the basic ideas of
generative grammar it had another paper
on problem solving and reasoning it was
a paper by herb Simon and Al Newell
simulation of a proof of theorem proving
in elementary logic and he argues that
that confluence of of research papers
essentially initiated the the modern
field well there were some shared ideas
among the participants one shared idea
was a kind of shift in perception or
perspective toward the disciplines a
shift which is not terribly surprising
now but was pretty striking at that
moment the shift was away from the study
of behavior and the products of
behaviors such as words or sounds or
their arrangement in texts a shift from
that focus toward the study of the
states and properties of the mind and
the brain that enter into human thought
and action from the first point of view
which overwhelmingly prevailed at the
time
behavior and its products were regarded
as the object of study from the second
point of view what later came to be
called the cognitive sciences behavior
and its products were of no particular
interest in themselves they simply
provided data data which would be
interesting insofar as it served as
evidence for what really concerns us now
the inner workings of the mind where the
phrase mind here simply is a way of
talking about relevant properties and
states and processes of the brain the
data of behavior and texts and so on
from this point of view are to be used
alongside of other data whatever might
turn out to be useful say electrical
activity the brain but it has no
inherently privileged status and it's
not the focus of interest that's a shift
it's a shift away from what was called
behavioral science or structuralism or
strike statistical analysis of texts and
a shift toward something that might
properly be called cognitive science in
my personal view it was a shift from a
kind of natural history to at least
potential natural science now that shift
was highly controversial at the time and
it still is and in fact if you were to
use such measures as amount of
government funding it would still be
very much in the minority but I think it
was the right move well that was one
kind of shared interest from independent
points of view there was no
communication among the people prior to
the meeting a second shared interest was
an interest in what we might call
computational representational systems
that means a way of looking at mental
activities and mental faculties at what
the brain is doing to look looking at
them as a kind of a software problem
that is a study of the mechanisms but
viewed from a particular abstract
perspective analogies can always be
misleading but one might compare this
approach to say chemistry about a
century ago we
there were notions like valence or
periodic table or organic molecule and
so on but they were not grounded in the
basic physics of the time they did the
results however and the ideas did
provide guidelines for what turned out
to be quite radical changes in physics
that were necessary to accommodate these
ideas chemistry was never actually
reduced to physics it would be more
accurate to say that physics was
expanded in a certain sense to chemistry
similarly computational representational
theories of the brain attempt to
establish States and properties that
have to be accommodated somehow in the
brain sciences and might well provide as
far as they're correct they might well
provide guidelines for inquiry into
mechanisms it's possible again that they
may provide guidelines for what will
have to be radical changes in the in the
way that the brain and its processes and
states are conceived how two approaches
to the natural world will be unified if
ever can never be get guessed in advance
really could be reduction as in the
chemistry as in say the biology
chemistry case more or less it could be
which Michel expansion is in the physics
chemistry case or it could be something
else
crucially there's nothing mysterious
about any of this it seems to me at
least to be just normal science normal
science at a typical stage before
unification of several approaches to
some area I think some topic in the
natural world before they're unified
well again that was and remains highly
controversial assuming it anyway how can
we proceed you can look at the brain
and/or the person from number of
different points of view let's begin by
taking what you might call a receptive
point of view so we think of the brain
say as being in a certain state a signal
reaches the brain it produces some kind
of symbolic representation of the signal
internally presumably and it moves to
some others
if we focus on the interstate
transitions we're looking at problems of
learning or maybe more accurately growth
if we focus on the input signal and the
symbolic representation of it we're
looking at perception if we focus on the
initial state of the system prior to any
relevant signals we're looking at the
biological endowment the innate
structure we could trace the processes
back further at that point we'd be
moving into embryology and one should
stress that these distinctions are
pretty artificial actually typically the
systems that we're looking at are like
physical organs or we might say more
accurately like other physical organs
because we are studying a physical organ
from a particular point of view the
they're like physical organs other
physical organs in that say like the
digestive system or the circulatory
system or the visual system or whatever
which again we often look at abstractly
as one would expect in the study of the
system of any degree of complexity we
can call these particular systems mental
organs not implying again anything more
than that they are involved in what
we're traditionally called mental States
mental faculties or mental processes
well like other physical organs these
mental organs quite typically reach a
kind of a stable state at a certain
point that is the input signal that's
causing an interstate transition sort of
moves the system around within some kind
of equivalence class of states that are
alike for purposes at hand that's
obviously an idealization but a
reasonable one when you look at the
stable state after the point at which
there isn't significant change then
you're very clearly studying perception
when you look at the signal result
relationship so for example if you take
the visual system if you look at the
initial state the state prior to
relevant signals you're looking at the
basic structure of the visual system
the interstate transition you're looking
at the growth of the visual system the
changes in the distribution of vertical
and horizontal receptors in the strike
cortex or the onset of binocular vision
after a couple months of age and humans
and so on if you look at the stable
state you're studying adult perception
adult perception of course has some kind
of access to systems of belief about the
world not much is known about this but
it seems reasonable to assume that that
involves some kind of computational
procedure that specifies an infinite
range of beliefs which are called upon
when needed
although here we move into a domain of
almost total ignorance turning to the
language system you can look at it the
same way the initial state of the system
the initial state of the language
faculty the study of it is sometimes
called universal grammar these days the
study the initial state of the language
faculty is the study of that is a study
of biological endowment it's an
empirical fact which seems pretty
well-established
that this element of the brain is pretty
uniform across the species the
variations appear to be quite slight
apart from extreme pathology and it also
appears to be unique in essentials I
thought there's no other known organism
that has anything like it also it's
rather different from other biological
systems in many respects systems of
discrete infinity which this plainly is
are pretty rare in the biological world
so it appears the if you're looking at
the interstate transition as signals
some relevant information comes in
you're studying language acquisition it
apparently reaches a stable state at
about puberty the this stable steady
state incorporates a computational
procedure which characterizes an
infinite set of expressions each of them
having a certain array of properties
properties of Centon properties of
meaning properties of structural
organization
that computational procedure constitutes
a person's language to have such a
procedure in the appropriate part of the
brain is to have a language or as we
sometimes say to know a language when I
speak of a language I simply mean the
computational or a generative procedure
that specifies the properties of a
infinite range of linguistic expressions
such as say the one I just produced
since your language is similar enough to
mine when the signal that I just
produced reaches your brain your
generative procedure constructs an
expression a set of an expression with
these properties which is similar enough
to the one that I form so we understand
one another more or less
unlike the system of belief that's
accessed in visual perception in this
case we happen to know quite a lot about
the generative procedures that are
involved in the use of language and even
about their innate invariant bases and
these in fact are the areas of major
progress in the past generation well
what about perception of language there
is there are bunch there are several
common assumptions about this one major
assumption is that there is something
called a parser a parser is something
that Maps a signal into a symbolic
representation paying no attention to
any other aspects of the relevant
environment of the environment of course
it is assumed that people are rational
that this parser accesses the generative
procedure that is it's assumed that you
use your knowledge of English when you
interpret signals note however several
assumptions first one assumption is that
such a thing exists that a parser exists
there is some Faculty of the mind that
interprets signals independently of any
other features of the environment that's
not at all obvious the existence of an
internal generative procedure is farm
were secure and far more obvious than
they exist the question of the existence
of a parser and it's also far better
grounded
assumption far better grounded
empirically and with much richer
theoretical structure this is contrary
to common belief which usually considers
the to the other way around
nevertheless let's assume that a parser
exists though it isn't obvious it's
further assumed that the parser doesn't
grow the way a language grows from some
initial state to a stable state now that
assumption again is not very well
founded it's based mainly on ignorant
it's the simplest assumption and we have
no reason to believe anything about it
so we might as well believe that there
is some kind of evidence for it indirect
perhaps but interesting there is a
forthcoming book coming out from MIT
press by Robert Berwick and Sandow a fun
former student of his on what you might
call a universal parser a fixed
invariant parser which has the property
that if you sort of flip it switches one
way it interprets English and if you
flip its switches another way it
interprets Japanese and if that's the
right idea then there is a universal
parser which is unaffected by
environmental factors apart from the
properties that serve to identify one or
another language that is the array of
flipping of switches I'll come back to
that there's a further comment so that
assumption the assumption that the
partial doesn't grow well strange could
be true and there's only this kind of
indirect evidence worth a further common
assumption is that parsing is easy
something that the brain that you do
very quickly and easily
in fact that's often held to be a
criterion for the theory of language
it's often held to provide it it's the
criterion it's supposed to be that the
theory of language must provide
generative procedures that satisfy this
requirement that parsing is easy easy
and quick well that one's flatly false
uncontroversially parsing often fails
completely and quite systematically and
it's often extremely difficult many
categories of what are called parsing
failure
are known even with short simple
expressions a parsing failure just means
a case where the parser works fine but
it gives some kind of an interpretation
which is not the one that's assigned to
the signal by the by the language so
it's wrong in that sense the it's
perfectly true that when and very often
you know you can easily find categories
of experiment of expressions even pretty
simple ones where the parsing system
just breaks down people don't know what
they're hearing sounds like gibberish
even though it's perfectly well-formed
and has fixed strict meaning so on and
so forth now it's perfectly true that
one uses expressions that are readily
parsed but that verges on tautology what
it means is we use what is usable other
resources of the language we just don't
use there's a related assumption it's
often alleged that language is well
adapted to the function of communication
it's not clear that that statement is
even meaningful or any similar
statements about biological organs but
to the extent that one can give some
meaning to that statement
this one again looks just false the
design of language appears to make it
largely unusable which is fine we just
use those fragments that are usable for
us doesn't mean that design made it
usable somehow there are similar
assumptions in learnability theory
formal learning ability theory it's
often claimed as a starting point that
natural languages must be learning in
fact natural language is often defined
natural languages are defined often as
the set of languages that are learn
about conditions now notice that that
could be true we don't know that that's
false as we know that the comparable
statement about parsing is false it
could be true that languages are
learning but it's not a conceptual
necessity language design might be such
that's our language faculty could be
such that it permits all kinds of
inaccessible languages these would be
realized realizable in the brain just as
say English is but not accessible to
humans
again that wouldn't stop us from doing
what we do we would just pick up the
accessible ones in fact there is some
recent work quite recent work which
suggests that natural languages are
learning but if true that's an empirical
discovery and in fact the rather
surprising one well I've said nothing so
far about production of language there's
a reason for that the reason is that
apart from very peripheral aspects it's
almost a complete mystery we can learn a
good deal about the mechanisms that are
put to use when we speak and we can
study these certain aspects of
perception the mapping of of signals to
percept using the internalized
mechanisms the generative procedure of
the language but no one has anything
sensible to say about what I'm doing now
or what two people are doing in a normal
conversation it was observed centuries
ago that the normal use of language has
quite curious properties it is unbounded
it's not random it is not determined by
external stimuli and there's no reason
to believe that it's determined by
internal States its uncaused but it's
somehow appropriate to situations it's
coherent it evokes in in the here
thoughts that he or she might have
expressed the same way that collection
of properties we can call them the
creative aspect of language use that set
of properties was regarded by the
Cartesians as the best evidence that
another organism has a mind like ours
not just a body like a dog or a monkey
or a robot actually if you look back at
their argument it was quite reasonable
the science happen to be wrong but it
was very reasonable and within the
framework of scientific reasoning we
might put matters in different terms but
we haven't made any progress in
understanding these critically important
phenomena the phenomena that concerned
them and that lot rely much they provide
much of the basis for the
no mind-body distinction in my opinion
in fact contemporary thought about these
topics usually phrased in terms of
notions like the Turing test involves a
considerable regression from the much
more scientific approach of Cartesian
psychology I'm gonna have time to
elaborate properly I merely mention this
to provoke some possible interest or
maybe outrage
well I've mentioned several kinds of
shared interest in the early modern
cognitive sciences back to the 1956
meeting that George Miller
pointed to one common interest again is
in computational representational
systems looking at the brain in terms of
software problems for linguistics at
least this be turned into the study of
the generative procedures that are put
to use in perception and presumably an
expression of thought speaking although
the latter again remains a complete
mystery there's another shared interest
it's what we might call the unification
problem that's a problem that has two
different aspects one aspect is the
relation between the hardware and the
software the relationship between
computational representational theories
of the brain and what and the entities
that they postulate and what you might
call implementation and as I suggested I
think you can regard that as similar to
the problem of the relation between say
chemistry and physics 100 years ago or
genetics and chemistry 50 years ago and
so on that's one problem the unification
general the one aspect of the
unification problem the deepest aspect a
less deep aspect has to do with the
relation among the various domains of
cognitive science say language and
vision whatever may be involved in
problem solving this is the question
what do they have in common
notice that that's much less profound a
problem if it turns out the answer is
nothing just the way it is on the other
hand we'd be kind of upset if the answer
to the first one was no answer
well at this point some of my skepticism
begins to surface so let's take the
first one the deep problem the serious
scientific problem the relation between
roughly the hardware and the software
chemistry and physics here there are two
different approaches you can identify
one approach let's call it naturalistic
says goes kind of like this it says the
mental organs are viewed as
computational representational systems
and we want to show that they're real
that their statements in in these
theories are true that is there are
certain states of the properties of the
brain which these theories exactly
capture in what you try to show the
mental organs can also be viewed in
other ways for example you can look at
them in terms of cells or atoms or more
interestingly for the moment you can
look at them in terms of electrical
activity of the brain so called
event-related potentials ERP
now rather surprisingly there's some
recent work which shows quite dramatic
and surprising correlations between
certain properties of the computational
representational systems of language and
of ERPs potentials for the moment these
ERP measures have no status apart from
their correlation with categories of
expressions that come out of
computational representational theories
they're just numbers sort of picked at
random they don't have any because
there's no there's no relevant theory
about them that says just look at these
numbers and not at some other numbers in
themselves in other words they're
curiosities still it's interesting
because they do are there are
correlations to rather subtle properties
that have emerged in the attempt to
develop computational representational
theories which explain the form and
meaning of language so that suggests an
interesting direction for research
namely to try to unify these quite
different approaches to the brain and to
place each of them in an appropriate
theoretical context for them all
that's primarily a problem for the RPS
but if you can pursue it could be quite
an interesting direction one can think
of lots of consequences well the same is
true of the relation between C our
systems computational representational
systems and physiology at least in
principle here it's just in principle
because in practice at present we don't
really have much to look at there except
from the theories of the computational
representational systems but here
whatever the difficulties may be we seem
to face ordinary problems of science
before the typical situation when
alternative approaches don't there's no
understood way to unify them or connect
them well there's a different approach
to this unification problem which
actually dominates contemporary thinking
about cognitive science not necessarily
the actual work but the thinking about
what it amounts to this approach is to
divorce the study of mental organs from
the biological setting altogether and to
ask whether some simulation can
essentially fool an outside observer so
we asked whether the simulation passes
some rather arbitrary test called the
Turing test but Turing test is just a
name for a huge battery of possible
tests and so we can pick out one of
those kind of at random and we now ask
whether some say extraterrestrial
invented organism or some actual program
computer passes the test that is fool
somebody and people write articles in
which they ask how can we determine
empirically whether an extraterrestrial
or a program computer or machine can say
play chess or understand Chinese and the
answer is supposed to be if it can fool
an observer under some arbitrary
conditions called the Turing test then
we say we've empirically established
that actually you may have noticed last
November there was a big splash about a
running of the Turing test over the
Boston computer museum with together
with the Cambridge Center for behavioral
studies and a quite distinguished panel
that a bunch of programs which are
supposed to try to fool people otherwise
I think $100,000 prize offered big story
in The Boston Globe front-page story in
The New York Times science had a big
splash on it I wasn't there but I'm told
that the program that did best and
fooling people into thinking that it was
a human was one that produced cliches at
random apparently did pretty well I
don't tell you something about humans
but I'm not sure what as far as I can
see all of this is entirely pointless
it's like asking how we could determine
empirically whether an airplane can fly
the answer being if it can fool someone
into thinking that it's an eagle say
under some conditions but the question
whether an airplane can fly and whether
it's really flying or for that matter
the question whether high jumpers were
really flying at the last Olympics
that's not an empirical question that's
a matter of decision and different
languages make decisions differently so
if you're speaking Japanese I'm told
airplanes
eagles and high jumpers all are really
flying if you're talking English
airplanes and eagles are really flying
but humans aren't except metaphorically
if you're talking Hebrew Eagles are
flying and neither airplanes and or
humans are but it's that's just a matter
of there's no substantive issue involved
there's nothing that is to determine no
question to answer a simulation of an
eagle could have some purposes of course
say learning about Eagles or maybe
solving some problem in aerodynamics but
fooling an observer under some variety
of the Turing test is not a sensible
purpose as far as I can see as far as
I'm aware there's nothing like this in
the sciences incidentally if you go back
to the 17th and 18th centuries
scientists were
very much intrigue all philosophers were
but they didn't distinguish where they
were greatly intrigued by automata by
machines for example automata that
simulated say the digestion of a duck
but their goal was to learn about ducks
not to answer meaningless questions
about whether machines can really digest
as proven by the fact that they can fool
an observer let's just say looking
behind a screen or something
however they may be doing it well this
is one of the respects in which in my
opinion at least there's been regression
since the 17th and 18th century chess
playing programs are a perfect example
of this in my opinion well anyway that's
two approaches to the first question of
unification the sort of deep one what
about the more shallow question of
unification that is the question of
unification among the various branches
of the cognitive sciences is there any
real commonality among them well that
doesn't seem entirely obvious so take
what you know you might think of what
you might call physical organs below the
neck metaphorically speaking meaning not
the ones we call mental say take the
circulatory system and the digestive
system visual system and so on these are
organs of the body and some reasonable
sense viewed abstractly and that's a
normal way to study any complex system
the study of these abstract organs does
fall together at some level we assume
presumably at the level of cellular
biology but it's not at all clear that
there's any other level that is that
there's some kind of organ theory at
which these systems are unified maybe
but it's not obvious well the brain is
scarcely understood but to the extent
that anything's understood about it it
appears to be an extremely intricate
system heterogeneous with all kind of
sub parts that have special design and
so on and there's no special reason to
suppose that the metal organs are
unified in some kind of mental organ
Theory above the level of cellular
biology that is above the level at which
they may fall together with the search
taury system and so on if there is no
intermediate level no such unification
then there is no cognitive science hence
there was no cognitive revolution except
for similarities of perspective which
could be quite interesting in fact well
there are various speculations about
this question in fact they go right back
to that 1956 meeting one general line of
speculation is that the mind is what's
called modular that is that metal organs
have special design like everything else
we know in the physical world the other
the other approach assumes uniformity
that there are what are called general
mechanisms of learning or thinking which
are just applied to different domains
they're applied to language or to chess
and so on and as I say these differences
they didn't exactly surface but they
were more or less implicit at the 1956
meeting the paper on generative grammar
took for granted modularity that is a
rich specific genetic endowment the
language faculty special system and no
general mental organ theory the Newell
simón approach study the logic machine
that took for granted the opposite
position that is that there are general
mechanisms of problem-solving which are
quite indifferent as to subject matter
in our case they are improving but
equivalently chess or language or
whatever and you can trace these
different intuitions back quite a way
back hundreds of years in fact they're
very lively today and the discussion is
about connectionist work for example my
own view is that the evidence is
overwhelmingly in favor of the highly
modular approaches there are only a few
areas where we have any real insight and
these invariably seem to involve quite
special design possibly there are some
unifying principles but about these if
they exist nothing much is understood
again that's my already view but the way
it looks to me even internal to the
language faculty there seems to be quite
highly modular does
so let's distinguish roughly between
what we might call grammatical ability
meaning the ability to produce properly
forms expressions and conceptual ability
that is to produce expressions that
somehow make some sense and pragmatic
ability that is the ability to use
expressions in some way appropriate to
the occasion
well these capacities have been
discovered to be disassociated
developmentally like one can develop and
the others not and selectively impaired
under injury and their properties are
quite different and they seem to be
radically different from what we find in
other cognitive systems so even
internally just at the most gross look
we seem to find modularity and when you
look more closely into subsystems of
language they just seem to behave rather
differently I don't see why they should
surprise anyone
it's exactly what we find about every
other biological organism so why
shouldn't it be true of the brain which
is maybe the most complex one around but
it's considered a very controversial
position again I stress as far as I know
all the evidence supports it and it
shouldn't be surprising well on the
other hat just how modular is the
language faculty that's an interesting
question it doesn't seem so special that
it's linked to particular processing
systems here study of sign language in
the last in the last decade or so maybe
20 years has been quite interesting
rather surprisingly it seems that sign
language the normal language of the deaf
sign language is localized in speech
areas of the brain in the left
hemisphere not in the visual processing
areas which you might expect since you
see it you don't hear it that's shown
pretty well by aphasia studies and again
ERP studies also turns out that children
who were acquiring sign language in a
natural setting go through steps at
least in the early stages which have
been studied that are remarkably similar
to the acquisition of spoken language
the timing and everything else they even
override obvious iconic properties of
visual symbols so pointing is overridden
and given a symbolic interpretation
furthermore acquisition of sign language
turns out to be quite different from
acquisition of communicative gestures
there's even one case on record of
spontaneous invention of sign language
by three deaf children who had no
environmental model and no stimulus at
all as far as anyone can be determined
that's the perfect experiment the system
that these three kids constructed has
very standard properties of natural
language natural spoken language and the
developmental stages also appear to be
similar that looks like about a pure
expression of the language faculty
unaffected by experience and it suggests
that however modular the system maybe
it's not so modular that it's keyed to a
particular mode of articulation or input
what's now known suggest that the
language faculty simply grows a language
much as other organs of the body grow
and it does so in a way largely
determined by its inner nature by
properties the initial state external
events doubtless have some kind of an
effect like I'm talking English not
Japanese but a rational Martian
scientist who is looking at us would
probably not find these variations very
impressive and the language that grows
in the mind appears to be at least
partially independent of sensory
modality well at this point we're moving
towards serious inquiry into modular
architecture architecture of mind and
brain in some of the few areas where
it's possible to undertake it and with
some surprising results well one last
element of skepticism about the
cognitive revolution has to do with just
how much of a revolution it was in fact
to a far greater extent than was
realized at that time whereas even
generally recognized today the shift in
perspective in the 1950s recapitulated
and rediscovered some long-forgotten
ideas and insights from what you might
call the first cognitive revolution
which pretty much coincided with the
Scientific Revolution of the 17th and
18th centuries now the galilean
Newtonian revolution in physics is well
known the Cartesian revolution and its
aftermath and psychology and physiology
is not very well known but it was quite
dramatic and it had important effects
important consequences it developed some
also developed some of the major themes
that were taken up again since the 1950s
primarily in the areas of language and
vision which are perhaps the most
successful branches of contemporary
cognitive science as well now this first
cognitive revolution though it had a
great deal of interest than as much you
can learn from it in it did face
barriers in fact they were insuperable
barriers so for example in the study of
language it came to be realized soon
enough that human language is somehow a
process not just a dead product it's not
a bunch of text at some process that
goes on furthermore it's a process that
makes infinite use of finite means as
the Humboldt put it in the early 19th
century but no sense could be made of
these ideas and the inquiry aborted
aborted for well over a century by this
century the formal Sciences had provided
enough understanding of all of this so
that many traditional themes could be
productively engaged particularly
against the background of other advances
in science and engineering and
anthropological linguistics and one
could understand quite well what it
meant to make infinite use of finite
means well let's turn to a quick look at
some of the kinds of questions that
arise and some of the kinds of answers
that can be offered with respect to
language specifically so take something
that everybody knows something start
with something really trivial very
simple so take a simple phrase like say
Brown House you and I have generative
procedures which are more or less
similar and these generative procedures
determine what we know about this
expression for example we know that it
consists of two words we know that those
two words have the same vowel for most
speakers we know also that if is
something rather
to something I say that's a brown house
what I mean is its exterior is brown if
you if somebody paints a house brown we
know that they painted the exterior
brown if they painted the inside brown
they didn't paint the house brown if you
see a house you see its exterior so we
can't see this building as a matter of
conceptual necessity if we were standing
outside we might and the same is true of
a whole mass of what are sometimes
called container words like box or igloo
or airplane you can see an airplane for
example if you're inside it but only if
you can look at the window and see the
wings or if there's a mirror outside
which reflects the exterior of the
airplane or something like that then you
could see the airplane otherwise not the
same is true with invented concepts even
impossible concept so say take a
spherical Q if somebody paints a
spherical cube Brown that means they
painted the exterior Brown not the
interior so all of these a house that
setting all these things are exterior
surfaces which is kind of curious to
start with however they're not just
exterior x' so suppose two people say
John and Mary are equidistant from the
exterior regarded as a mathematical
object suppose they're equidistant from
the exterior but John is outside it and
Mary's inside it we can ask whether John
the guy outside is near the house or
whatever it is and there's an answer
depending on current criteria for
nearness but we can't ask it about Mary
we're not near this building no matter
what the criteria are so it's not just
an exterior it's an exterior plus
something about a distinguished interior
however the nature of that interior
doesn't seem to matter very much so it's
the same house if you say take it and
fill it with cheese or something like
that you change the exterior it's the
same house hasn't changed at all on the
other hand and similarly we can move the
walls around and it stays the same house
on the other hand you can clean a house
and not touch the exterior at all you
can only do things to the interior so
somehow it's a
a special combination of a abstract
though somehow concrete interior with an
abstract exterior and of course the
house itself is perfectly concrete same
is true of my home that's also perfectly
concrete but in a quite different way if
a house is a brown wooden house it has a
brown exterior surface but it doesn't
just have a wooden exterior it's both a
concrete object of some kind and an
abstract surface as well as having a
distinguished interior with weird
properties
well proceeding further we discover that
container words like say house have
extremely weird properties certainly
there can't be any object in the world
that has this combination of properties
nor do we believe that there is rather a
word like house provides a certain quite
complex perspective for looking at what
we take to be things in the world
furthermore these properties are
completely unlearned hence they must be
universal and as far as we know they are
they're just part of our nature we
couldn't we didn't learn them we
couldn't have learned them they're also
largely unknown and unsuspected take the
most extensive dictionary you like say
the big oxford english dictionary that
you read with a magnifying glass and you
find that it doesn't dream of such
semantic properties rather what the
dictionary does is offer some hints that
allow a person who already knows almost
everything to pick out the intended
concept and the same is true of world of
words generally and in fact the same is
true of the sound system of language
they are largely known in advance in all
they're quite remarkable intricacy hence
their Universal a species property the
external environment may fix some
details the way the Oxford English
Dictionary can fix a few details but
language acquisition and in fact
probably a good deal what's misleadingly
called learning is really a kind of
biological growth where you kind of fill
in details in an extremely rich
predetermined structure that just goes
back to your nature very much like
physical growth or as I think we should
say other aspects of physical growth
well if you look at the structure of
more complex expressions then these
conclusions are just reinforced again
let me take pretty simple cases to
illustrate so take the sentence say John
ate an apple and drop out the word apple
and you get John eight and what that
means everyone knows is John ate
something or other so if you eliminate
phrase from the sentence you interpret
it as something or other John eight
means John ate something rather more or
less take the sentence a little bit
longer but not much
John is too stubborn to talk to Bill
well that means John is so stubborn that
he won't talk to Bill and just as in the
case of John ate an apple dropped the
last phrase bill and we get John is too
stubborn to talk to and by analogy or by
induction if such a thing existed people
ought to interpret it as meaning John is
so stubborn that he won't talk to
someone or other however it doesn't mean
that John is too stubborn to talk to
means John is so stubborn that nobody's
going to talk to him John
somehow it all inverts if I drop the
last word I suppose you make it a little
more complex
John is too stubborn to expect anyone to
talk to Bill
well that means John if to think maybe a
little bit here already John because
parsing is not easy and quick John is
too stubborn
it means John is too stubborn for him
John to expect that anyone will talk to
Bill and I'll drop bill again and we get
John is too stubborn to expect anyone to
talk to and reflect for a moment and
you'll see that the meaning shifts
radically it means John is so stubborn
that somebody or other doesn't expect
anyone to talk to him John everything
shifts now all of this is inside you
nobody could ever learn it nobody could
possibly learn it none of it is
mentioned even and they're hinted at in
fact even in the most comprehensive
grammar books it's known without
experience its universal as far as we
know in fact it better be Universal or
it means their genetic differences
crucially among people it just grows out
from our nature a huge
variety of material of that sort has
come to light in the last 30 years or so
as a direct consequence of something new
namely the attempt to actually discover
and to formulate the generative
procedures that grow in the language
Faculty of the brain virtually without
experience that had never been done
before it was always assumed that it's
kind of all obvious you know how could
it actually be anything complicated here
if you go back say to the early 50s the
problem about language acquisition was
supposed to be why does it take so long
why does it take so long for such a
trivial thing to happen why do children
need so much exposure to material to do
this simple process of habit formation
as soon as you try to describe the facts
you discover that it's quite the
opposite there's extremely intricate
things that are known even in the
simplest cases there's no possible way
of picking them up from experience and
consequently their universal they're
part of our nature these are just part
of the general generative procedures
that the brain determines well what do
these generous procedures look like
apparently they look something like this
a language can be looked at as involving
a computational procedure and what you
can call a lexicon a lexicon is a
selection of concepts that are
associated with particular sounds the
concepts appear to be pretty much
invariant they're things like house
let's say and they have very weird
properties which means that they must be
invariant because if they have very
weird properties they've got to be
unlearned which means that they're going
to be invariant just part of our nature
the sound variety also seems quite
limited on the other hand the
association between a concept and a
sound looks free so you can say tree in
English and Bauman German and so on so
that tells us what one aspect of
language acquisition is it's determining
which of the given set of concepts with
all their richness and complexity is
associated with which of the possible
sounds with their limited variety notice
that that's pretty trivial task
so you can you can imagine how a little
bit of experience could help fix those
concept those associations if the
concepts were given and the structure of
the sound was given well the lexicon
also contains what are sometimes called
formal elements things like inflections
like tense or plural or case markers of
the kind that you find say in German or
Latin and so on and languages do appear
to differ quite substantially in these
respects however that seems to be mostly
allusion at least the more we learn the
more it looks like illusion so for
example take say cases English doesn't
have them you got to memorize them when
you study German and Latin but that
looks illusory it appears to be the case
that English hasn't fine in fact exactly
the way Latin has them it's just that
they don't happen to come out the mouth
they're not articulated they're in the
internal mental computation and their
effects which are quite ramified are
detectable but that part of the
computation just doesn't happen to link
up to the vocal tract so the computation
is running along but where it gets
spelled out of sounds it just didn't
happen to look at this stuff
well that's another aspect of language
acquisition that is to determine what
aspects of the computational system
receive an external articulation there
are also some differences among these
formal elements that also have to be
fixed but they appear pretty narrow
notice incidentally that if you have a
very intricate system with just a few
possible differences in it which could
be sort of right at the core somewhere
model-making those changes may produce
something that looks phenomenally quite
quite different just look at it from the
outside and they look radically
different even though it's basically
basically the same thing with really
only trivial differences and that's
pretty much what languages seem to look
like well what about the computational
system that's the lexicon what about the
computational system it's possible that
it's unique that is it's invariant
there's just one of them there's nothing
at all to be learned it's not certain
but it's at least possible in fact
plausible if this picture is on the
right track notice we're very close to
concluding that there's only one human
language at least in its deep
aspects and instantly going back to this
rational Martian scientist that's what
he would have guessed in the first place
otherwise acquisition of these highly
intricate systems on the basis of
fragmentary experience and the
uniformity of the process would just be
a miracle so the natural assumption as
well as basically only one of them and
it's fixed in advance if in fact
acquisition of language is something
like a chicken embryo becoming a chicken
or humans undergoing puberty at a
certain age then it's at least within
the realm of potential scientific
understanding not a miracle and that's
the way it seems to be the more we learn
the more it looks like that more
precisely there does seem to be a
certain variety of languages apparently
a finite variety that is it does seem to
be the cure it's a good guess now that
each lying each possible language that
the language faculty makes available
each possible language is fixed by
answering a finite number of fairly
simple questions you can look at the
system as being sort of like a the
complex wired up thing which is just
given with a switch box associated with
it and a finite number of switches you
can flip them up you can flip them down
you do that on the basis of the answer
to one or another of these questions and
they got to be pretty simple questions
if we could understand the way that
works bits and pieces of it are
understood if suppose we could
understand it then we ought to be able
to say deduce Hungarian by setting the
switches one way and deduce Swahili by
setting the switches a different way the
questions must be easily answered for
empirical reasons children do it highly
efficiently and very fast and with very
little evidence pretty much the way they
grow it follows that languages are
learning that is if this is correct it
follows that as I mentioned before
languages in fact are learner bull which
is an empirical discovery and a pretty
surprising one
no reason why I would have had that no
biological reason why it would have had
to be true but it looks that as though
it may be true
partly because largely because the
variety is so so restricted well
assuming that to be true we now have the
following situation languages appear to
be learn about which is surprising but
languages appear to be unusable which I
don't think is surprising at all what
that means is that only scattered parts
of them are usable and of course those
are the parts we use so we don't notice
it not actually this unusable 'ti
property may be somewhat deeper than
what I suggested since the origins of
modern generative linguistics there have
been attempts to show that the
computational system is constrained by
certain very general principles of
economy which have a kind of global
character to them and there's some
recent work that carries these ideas a
long step forward it's still pretty
tentative in fact it's unpublished but
let me sketch some leading ideas that
indicate where things might go suppose
we think of a linguistic expression
something in something like the
following way the language faculty
selects a certain array of items from
the lexicon that's what's going to talk
about and it begins computing away using
its computational procedure which I'm
now assuming to be invariant across
languages it it computes in parallel
just picks out these items and goes
computing along with them it
occasionally merges pieces as a
computation so you bring them together
and maybe pick something out and starts
going in parallel again at some point in
the computation they've all been merged
it just keeps computing it proceeds
merrily on its way in other words at
some point at after they've merged the
system the fact language faculty decides
to spell it out meaning to provide
instructions to the articulatory and
perceptual system then the computation
just keeps going on and it ultimately
provides something like a representation
of meaning which is probably to be under
stood as instructions for other
performance systems
well proceeding in this way the
computation ultimately proceeds to
paired symbolic expressions to paired
outputs instructions for the
articulatory perceptual apparatus on the
one hand and instructions for language
use called semantics sometimes so these
are the two let's call them interface
levels the language faculty the language
faculty seems to interface with other
systems of the mind performance systems
at two points one having to do with
articulation and perception the other
having to do with with the things you do
with language referring to things asking
questions and so on
roughly semantics the so let's say
that's what happens looks like it does
now of these various computations only
certain of them have converge in a
certain sense the sense is that the two
kinds of outputs the phonetic are
instructions the articulatory perceptual
system and semantics actually yield
interpretive instructions like they
might compute along and end up with an
outfit that doesn't yield interpretable
instructions in that case if either one
of them fails we say that it doesn't
converge now looking just at the
convergent ther evasions the convergent
computations those that yield
interpretable paired outputs some of
them are blocked by the fact that others
of them are more economical that as they
involve less computation now here you've
got to define amount of computation and
a very special and precise sense but
it's not an unnatural sense well if you
can do this it's going to turn out that
many instructions that would be
perfectly interpretable just can't be
constructed by the mind at least by the
language faculty because the outputs are
blocked by more economical derivations
what is the linguistic expression then
well a linguistic expression is nothing
other than the optimal realization of
certain external interface conditions a
language is the setting of
certain switches and an expression of
the language is the optimal realization
of universal interface conditions period
all the work would now be done by
special properties of the nature of
computation and very special notions of
economy which do have a kind of global
character they have a kind of a least
effort character but of a global sort
well it turns out that quite a variety
of strange things can be explained in
these ways in terms of a picture of
language that is really rather elegant
it's guided by conditions of economy of
derivation with very simple and
straightforward operations they're not
only elegant but they're pretty
surprising for a biological system in
fact these properties are more like the
kind of what one expects to find for
quite unexplained reasons in the
inorganic world
well these economy conditions that I
mentioned I have a sort of a global
character to them though not entirely
they have a tendency to yield high
degrees of computational complexity that
would render large parts of language
unusable well that's not necessarily an
empirical objection we then turned to an
empirical question are the parts that
are rendered unusable the parts that
can't be used we know there are plenty
of parts that can't be used so if turns
out that parts of language involve
computational irresolvable computational
complexity it resolved by a reasonable
device and those are the parts you can't
use fine that's positive result not a
negative result well what we might
discover then if this continues to look
as promising is it think it does now
what we might discover is that languages
are learn about because there isn't much
to learn that they're unusable in large
measure but that they're surprisingly
beautiful which is just another mystery
if it turns out to be true Thanks
you